a new survey reveals more than a quarter
of adults admit that they don't always
buckle up in the backseat research by
the Insurance Institute for Highway
Safety found that 91% of adults say they
always wear their seat belt in the front
seat but only 72% are as diligent in the
rear Kris Van Cleave shows us why this
important habit is just not clicking so
to speak
Kris good morning good morning a nearly
half of all the people killed in car
crashes weren't wearing their seat belts
but as more and more of us spend more
and more time in the back seats of say
cabs or ubers this new research out
today seems to show we're being lulled
into a false sense of security back here
this dashcam videos show the risks of
riding unbelted I always put my seat
belt on if I driving if I'm in the front
seat of a car yet marks MIGA says he
never buckles up in the back of a cab a
place especially prone to people riding
unbelted the survey by the Insurance
Institute for Highway Safety shows just
57% of passengers buckle up in higher
vehicles like taxis it's absolutely not
even part of my consciousness when we
ask people why they were less likely to
buckle up a quarter of the respondents
told us that it's safer in the backseat
so they don't need to buckle up but as
you can see here the unbelted woman on
the left flies across the cab and slams
into the window federal crash statistics
show passengers in the rear are three
times more likely to die if they aren't
wearing a seat belt even if you're in
the back seat the laws of physics are
not suspended you still need to buckle
up in order to get the best protection
in a crash that protection extends to
others in the car crash test videos show
an unbuckled dummy flying into the seat
in front of it crushing the driver into
the steering wheel you can see the
difference when both dummies are
strapped in every state but New
Hampshire requires adults to wear
seatbelts while sitting in the front but
21 states have no such requirements for
grown-ups in the back seat
and safety advocates are sounding the
alarm as more and more people are using
ride-hailing services and those people
are not buckling up at the same rate we
could see more people getting injured
and killed in the backseat 75% of the
people surveyed said all it would take
would be a friendly reminder to make
them more likely to wear their seat belt
in the back seat so Vlad a little bit of
friendly peer pressure can go a long way
absolutely Kris Van Cleave reporting
Thank You Kris